the former minneapolis police officer
convicted of murdering george floyd
learned his fate
on friday a judge sentenced derrick
chauvin to 22 and a half
years in prison that sentence is lighter
than the 30 years sought by prosecutors
but exceeds the 12 and a half years
recommended by state guidelines
chauvin and three fellow officers still
face a federal civil rights trial
chauvin knelt on floyd's neck for nearly
10 minutes
leading to his death it led to one of
the biggest outcries against racial
injustice in the nation's history
and as jamie lukas reports friday was
the first time chauvin broke his silence
in the courtroom
[Music]
black lives matter a vocal crowd
gathered outside the hennepin county
government center
to listen to derek chovin's sentence
when it was announced
many wished he had gotten more time i
mean you have to ask the question
is 22 years worth somehow it was an
emotional day in court friday when four
floyd family members provided victim
impact statements including floyd's now
seven-year-old daughter gianna
whose pain was recorded and played in
the courtroom i miss you and i love
you others spoke to chauvin directly
what was going through your head
when you had your knee on my brother's
neck i haven't had a real nice sleep
because of the nightmares i constantly
have hearing my brother big
and plead for his life chauvin was
convicted in april on three counts
including
second-degree murder the images of the
officer's knee on george floyd's neck
for more than nine minutes
ignited a call for police reform
everybody did their job today
and now hopefully the family will have
some level of
satisfaction knowing that george floyd's
life mattered
after the verdict attorney general keith
ellison told us this isn't justice but
is accountability and a step in the
right direction
when you look at all of the cases
brianna taylor our
ahmad arbory all these cases
we still haven't really embraced justice
even in terms of
putting a stop to the problem so i think
that this case does represent
accountability
it does signal the possibility of real
justice
but we're not there yet judge peter
cahill agreed with the prosecutor's case
that chauvin abused his position of
trust and authority as an officer
and that he treated floyd with
particular cruelty we need to recognize
the pain of the floyd family
before announcing a sentence of 22 and a
half years
10 years longer than what minnesota's
sentencing guidelines stated
and much longer than the defense's
request chauvin be released on probation
judge cahill asked jovin if he had
anything to say
the comments were brief i
do want to give my condolences to the
floyd family
there's going to be some other
information in the future that would be
of interest
and i hope things will give you some
some peace of mind thank you
chauvin now has 90 days to file an
appeal which he's almost certain to do
he also faces federal charges along with
those three other officers
if he's convicted of those charges he
could spend the rest of his life behind
bars
for cbs this morning saturday jamie
yukas minneapolis